Hello everyone and welcome to game number six of the 1971 semi-final match between bent Larsen and Bobby Fischer now
I hope you're having an excellent Saturday and hopefully this game will further improve your Saturday
that being said Ben Thorson is now in kind of in the position marked Amano found himself in if
It's not the score is now five to zero in Fischer's favor
And if he wants to at least draw this match or to allow for playoffs, he has the now Larsen would have to win five
five of the next games in a row which is highly unlikely because as we've already mentioned this during the
1971 in 1970 Interzone all tournament in palma de mallorca Bobby Fischer won seven of his last games in a row there then he continued
by defeating mark time at amount of six to zero and now he already
beat Ben force and five to zero, so it is very unlikely that
A Fisher will now lose five games in a row, but you know
it could happen and
We do have also I will be using some of the comments by mikhail tal from his shark a shark 64 magazine
Also, there will be a link to that in the description below if you want to check it out. I found a nice article from
Unchaste calm about it as someone
Delivered all the news from the newspapers there. So that being said, let's check out this game. So
So far Larson tried a lot of ideas now for the final well for the sixth game he opens with f4
He chooses the birds opening and here tall says that
Now it's pretty much clear that even Larsen came to terms with who is the winner of this match?
So perhaps he just wants to have fun
c5 was played Knight to f3 Fisher goes g6e for Bishop to g7 and Bishop to e2
Seems like a passive move with the bishop
But tell says that it's actually the correct idea if you try something like Bishop to c4
which seems like a much more active move after a 6 b5 will simply
Come with a tempo as it comes with an attack on the bishop and it will only help black
so a nice move Bishop to e2
Nice to see six with castles
D6 b3 e 6 and the knife to a3 it all says that this is a move very much characteristic
you know with Larsen style he wants to use well well-known or
Opening lines and the theory but also adds some of his own original style
Knight to G to e7 by Fischer c3 I would have castles the Bishop to e3 and now a six
As you can see Fischer has a rock on a eight perhaps the other local walls will also join
the Queen side this Bishop is slicing the board all the way here and Fischer will definitely want to
Resume play on the Queen side by pushing the pawns
So d4 here by Larson see chapters on d4, and now Knight captures on d4
Also if whites try something like see captors on d4 to to get this message center
Then f5 will be a very nice idea by black and black will be more than fine here
so after C captures
We have a knight capture Sun before and now b5 Fischer simply continues with his plan of playing on the Queen side
Knight captors on c6 Knight captures and now comes our Queen to d2
Tull mentions that also possible is of course Queen to e1 and transferring the Queen over to the King side and
Starting an attack against blacks King, but you know what? What else would it all suggests?
so Queen to d2 by Larson and now Queen to c7 and
Here rook a to be 1 by Larson. Now you could argue that. Okay, perhaps going to c7 now. The Queen is a bit misplaced
Maybe maybe an idea like f5 is worth considering and it's definitely worth considering
but black wouldn't be in any real danger here because after for example captures captures and Bishop captures
Let's say you even sacrifice in exchange here G captures. It's not all that
You know
trivial how to continue this attack group to f1
for example, maybe we want to get the rook in there, but then 95 comes you prevent prevent the rook lift and
Black black would most likely be okay here
But I'm sure there are there are plenty of people who would actually go for this
Such a stall so Queen to c7 we have rook a to D 1 but Larsson and now comes hook to d8
we have nice to see - and rook to b8 here tall says that this is a
Really a bold move by Fischer completely ignoring what Larsson is trying to do here
As you can see the bish of the being and c8 prevents the rooks from being connected
So e5 definitely a move you have to take into consideration before playing a move like rook to b8
But Fischer doesn't care he goes rook to b8. And now we have a three again. Larsen says that well if Tao says that
Still I move like Queen to e1. Sorry. I more like Queen to e1 with transferring the Queen over to the Kings side the
Would also be worth considering you know, why not start an attack against Blacks King, but okay rook to b8
We have a three by Larsson and now comes knife to a five by playing this a three move
Larson weakens the be three square also nice the c-4 will be an idea and the Fisher of course takes advantage of this immediately
e5
Fisher
Decided that this was, you know, not a problem for black so he allows it
bishop to f8, of course
You cannot capture because of Queen captures on d8 the so be sure to f8 defending and now B for kicking the knight back
Here knife the c-4 isn't all that great for black after Bishop captures and Queen captures
You can simply go brush up to d4 to you know
Solidify in the center and then after night comes to e3 kicks away. The Queen White's position will be very nice here
So after be for Fisher simply goes back Knight to c6
And here white is pretty much forced to capture on d6
but if you capture and Bishop captures then blacks position is is beautiful here and Larson will not be able to
Really do anything here
well, I mean he can of course always draw but a draw at this point is worth nothing to him, but
Even though he could have afforded a draw in Game five. He decided not to go for a draw in Game five either
So okay after this Knight to c6 by Fischer nice to d4
Now as a draws out of question Larsen decides to sacrifice a pawn and perhaps try an attack Fischer scheme
We have four captures pawn captures and Fischer grabs the pawn Knight captures on e5
Bishop to g5 attacking Fischer's rockin d8 and now rook to d5 an
Excellent defensive maneuver by Fischer because Bishop to e7 would actually allow white
Go for for something more after Bishop captures Queen captures you get this Queen to f4 move
The the the night is here attack. You can't move the night because the rocks aren't connected. The rockin b8 is undefended
So after rook to be 5 c4 and white black loses the exchange
For example captures captures and now your rook is under attack you if you move the rook you lose the night
so you have to capture here and then Queen captures on b8 and
You would you would lose the exchange here still it would be playable, but you know, no reason to do this
So rook the d5 Fischer holds that holds on to everything
Queen to f4 again
Pressuring pressuring the King side and now we have Bishop to g7
Queen captures on c3 is would it really have been a bold move?
But there's there's no reason to do it because after Bishop to f3 you again lose the exchange here. There's really nothing to do
Even if you go Knight captures on f3 would check you get rook captures on f3 and now it's even worse
Because your queen is under attack, you're getting crushed here Queen captures on f7 is coming and you can't defend with Queen c7
Because the Queen from f4 also guards
The c7 square. So after Queen to f4 Bishop to g7 by Fischer and now comes h4
We have rook to b7 Fischer now gets a really nice idea. He wants to introduce more defenders to the f7 square
But also this will allow his Queen to actually capture the pawn on c3
So, okay
We have Bishop to f6 Bishop captures Queen captures and here a lot of play a lot of people criticize
Fischer for this move because he is already up in material
He's already up a pawn and he should have gone for something like Queen to e7
This is what everyone suggested but he just went for Queen captures on c3
grabbing another pawn and now
He allows Larson to really start an attack Larson plays h5 and here it's really not all that clear now
What you should do, for example if you try rock captors on d4
You get three captures on e5 rook the d3 you offer a trade of Queens, but now Queen to f4
rook captures rook captures and after Bishop to d7
It's a pretty pretty okay game for both white and black white is very active here
No doubt say that he could hold this to a draw
on the other hand after this h5 movement and not capturing and before but for example Queen to e3
which comes with protection of the night here on e5 King gauge 1 and now rook after sandy for
It's not all that great because of rook captures and after Queen captures you get rook to d1 now
You can't move the Queen because the rook is coming to d8
And whatever you do have to capture the rook here and give up the Queen if you move the Queen
Then even h6 is coming in - now there is no defense against Queen to g7 checkmate
So after this h5 move Fischer actually plays G captures on h5 a very nice idea
We have king - h1 a nice prophylactic move and now comes knife to g4
Forcing forcing White's to capture the night. We have Bishop captures pawn captures, and now Queen to h6
If you try something like rook to c1 I would an attack on the Queen and the threat if the Queen moves you will capture
The bishop and see it doesn't work because of rook to h5
Check a king moves and now Queen to e3 check
Which comes with a check now if you block with the rock you lose the rock and c1?
and of course if you block with the Queen
Then you can simply exchange Queens and it's it's all fine for black Bishop to d7 is coming and you are simply up three points
easily winning an endgame
So k/h captors on g4 Larsen goes Queen to h6
Bishop to d7 by Fischer and the now comes rook to f4
Larsen still is playing for the win because s tal mentions rook captures on f7 is a pretty much a force to draw after King
captures the rook to f1
You have to block if you move the king then Queen to f8 is coming
So you have to block and now simply Queen captures on h7. King e8. You can go Queen h8
Check in get 7 - Queen here King gauge a king yet Queen a trade King f7 Queen to h7
Okay
You can never touch the e7 square because then Knight to f5 comes with check and then white will actually win this game now
But still after this Bishop to d7 by move by Fischer rook captures an f7 is a is a force to draw
Larsson a draw is pretty much the same as a defeat
Because in regards of who wins the match of course, so Luke 2:8 for by Larsson and now f5 by Fischer
still here after Queen to g5 check of
Larson could have drawn this game. For example King to f7
If King to f7 then queen g4, and then black would actually be in trouble as we'd have to go King. H8
And then again, it would result in a draw but like we said a Larson has to go for the win
so Queen to f6, but now
Finger goes Bishop to c8 a nice move with the best should be back
And now the Queen g5 will no longer achieve a draw for white as Fischer can simply bring the rook over into the defense?
Okay, rook F back to F 1 we have rook to f7 taking back the Queen Queen to h6
And now comes a bishop to b7 simply putting this bishop on a beautiful diagonal and now Fischer will start his own attack
Knight captures on e6 a very nice idea, but
Fischer allowed this for a reason Queen to f6 and the attack is repelled
Now if you if you trade Queens, of course, then rope captures rook captures and d5 Bishop captures
Black is up 2 points. Most likely most likely and easily winning end game for Fischer
So after Queen to f6 Queen back to e3 was played
Rook to e7 now piling up on the night because it's pinned
Rook to e1 and did not rook to d6 now with a triple attack against Larsen's night
so we have Queen to g5 check here Larsson forces the trade of Queens, but now it's
Far too late for such things
Queen captures Knight captures rook captures rook captures and rush up to d5
here Larsson played rook to e8 check and here we have our
King to g7 and it was in this position
unmoved 40 that
Bent Larsen resigned to the game and Fischer won yet another match in the candidate series with a result of 6 to 0
now before before I forget
We do have this photo it's a photo from the newspapers there. You can see it says underneath
Grandmaster Bobby Fischer of the United States studies the board before a move as he downed went Larsen of Denmark Tuesday night
In the sixth and deciding game of a ten game
World Chess Championship semi-final challenge series Fisher forced Larsson to resign after 40 moves in winning his sixth straight
Over the Danish champ. So there you have it also
I will put a link to this photo in the description if anyone wants to you know
Learn more about it. And as I don't want to forget these are the standings of the semi-finals
so as you can see in Denver Fischer defeated Larsson six to zero so that match lasted only six games and as you can see
Petrosyan unfortunately played the entirety of the match
So ten games were played and you can see the final result was five and a half to four and a half
Where nine games were drawn and only one game was won by Tigran Petrosian
So definitely a close match between Petrosyan and Korchnoi and okay
You might argue that Petrosyan had a tougher opponent that fortunately, you know in 1971 was a tougher opponent then Larsson
But still five and a half to four and a half and six to zero
You it it's not all that likely that
Petrosyan will be able to prevent Fisher from pursuing his you know
Dream of becoming world champion, but as this is our next stop in the series were definitely going to enjoy that
so yeah first
you know crushing the field in Palma the American 1917 then we we had a
Match would mark tomorrow in Vancouver Canada that ended six to zero
Then we have here in Denver, Colorado again the Fisher
You know presents brilliant play
with a result of six to zero against the bent Larsen and now after all of this
Has been played we have the final match against Tigran Petrosian
So Fisheries off to Buenos Aires to face the former world champion, so that's pretty much it for this game
It's very interesting. I will once again mention what about me Nick mentioned about this entire event. So before before facing Petrosyan?
Botanique says that it's very easy to see how Fischer won each one of his games
so if you analyze the games you can see that Fischer is just a better player and it's a
Pretty much clear. Hope you want every game but it's very hard to imagine how he won all the games 12 to 0
but when he does mention
Lasker's for example great results
You know against against Marshall and the Janoski and those were really really one of the most impressive results in chess history
You know match wise but still it was not a hundred percent against two of the strongest
Grandmasters in the world like Fischer did here. So this was unprecedented and everyone knew that
But winning even mentions his encounter with Fischer in the Varna Olympiad
When Fischer wasn't even twenty years old yet and bottoming says that he what he played Fischer. He understood that this is some
You know great chess force in front of him, even though he was such a such a young lad
But I bought when he said that
It was definitely not botanique who was deciding the tone of the battle and the ha how this was
Going to turn out
he said that Fischer was better at everything in that game and you know because he was better in in combinations that he
Achieved a winning position if you haven't seen that game
oh, I will also put a link to that game in the description below as it's the only game ever played between Bobby Fischer and
Mikhail Botvinnik
So that's that's pretty much it
I do. Hope you enjoyed this match this and that you're still enjoying the the Bobby Fischer series next stop
It's Buenos Aires and it's the match
finals of the 1971
Candidates Bobby Fischer vs. Tigran Petrosian
so I would like to thank Bettany love Chris Durant far shot every Nia and
Ryuga and Dustin young as poor for a contribution to my channel. Thank you a lot
I really appreciate it as usual. You can check two of my previous videos here
Thank you for watching and I'll see you soon. Most likely starting the Fisher versus
Petrosyan match thank you all and I'll see you soon